There's a fascinating
organization
called MAPS,
Multi-disciplinary Association
for Psychedelic Studies.
This is a nonprofit
think tank that
advocates for the
responsible investigation
of psychedelic
plant and chemicals
and exploring their potential
as tools for transformation,
for interpersonal
transformation.
And this is a moment
that we're living in now.
Right, we're kind of living
through a psychedelic
renaissance where, all
of a sudden, people
are starting to
take these tools,
these cognitive
technologies, that
have been used for thousands of
years a little more seriously.
We're starting to take
out the magnifying glass
and stop being alarmist and
actually paying attention
and studying the potential
of these tools, right?
So there's a fascinating
article written by Timothy Leary
back in the '60s
called Programming
the Psychedelic Experience.
And the idea here was that
if you could successfully
pattern and sequence the input
signals that the subject would
receive when he was on
a psychedelic odyssey,
you could literally
assure functional output.
You could almost guarantee
a functional catharsis,
that there would be of value
to the psychedelic session.
And he described the
psychedelic experience
as a period of
increased reactivity
to stimuli, both from
within and from without.
so you are immediately
plunged into a dialogue
with your own subconscious.
Things start to erupt.
Things start to emerge.
New patterns start
to be perceived.
And at the same time,
the world, becomes
like a Sensurround system,
the fidelity, the resolution
of the input
signals get boosted.
So all of a sudden,
you are overwhelmed,
almost eclipsed by
the signals coming in.
You are like a mind in flight.
You are in orbital position.
You are seeing the big picture.
But if you don't
have navigation,
if you don't pattern those
signals by carefully choosing
beautiful music, by
carefully curating
excellent ecstatic
poetry, reveries
that you can read
while you are tripping,
controlling the environment,
hanging around people
whose company induces
feelings of well-being,
by patterning those signals,
you're authoring the song.
The soul surfing that
you're actually doing.
The people that engage
in these mystical states
are known as psychonauts.
They're literally soul
surfers investigating psyche
through first person experience.
And there's all kinds of
answers that we can find within.
There's all kinds of
spaces that we can explore.
The new space is inner space.
And it's fascinating.
We have to look deeper
into this mystery.
We need to explore
these numinous realms,
the archetypal
realms from within.
We need to go Carl
Jung on our own brains
using a cocktail of
chemical technologies
that will thrust the
bodymind into liminal spaces
of exploration.
We need to engineer
inception-like dream spaces
to explore.
And the technologies are not
all going to be external.
Some of them are
going to be internal.
Computers are drugs but
drugs are computers.
This is the essence.
This is why we should
be open to this stuff
because it's
absolutely fascinating.
To check out MAPS,
Multi-disciplinary Association
for Psychedelic Studies.